ni
何には外音ですんですよ
私が入っをはじめから言うと日本の生命がに興味を持ってそういった作品をいろいろ
作ってきました
その一例が多いもので
もう外原っを代替するシステム srs は言っても作りましたこれは古いノートか
先生て脳科学者の方が作った
虚構ドレン児童の救えとオフからかせるシステムと合わせが元々作っていった
ちゃんと愛情やする代込みでございました
それとあの視覚と触覚起きませんことで奇皇后で探されるようになる作品ですねで退会
しついてこんな感じ
me
幸せな顔するんですけど傍から見てると代表さてにゃ者やばいやすい
ん
そういう作品なんでですがすごいみんな満足して風遠い
県だものに入るという感じですでこれいろいろ差異化してあってなんかあのう
ストーリー展開があるんですねで体験者の心拍恐れとっているんですけどドキドキする
とかば泉北のメッセージちゃいましたピーターが近づいてきてキスをしてくれるんです
が
ミスターや私がばしまうシアの詰め合わせてスッとやっているっていう
そういう正
座面は仮ですね
よしこういう作品をあのが約の頃からかれこれ5年くらいスペリアっ続けてしまって
でまぁそういう人みたいなハゲの命になってたんですけど最近11年間くらい
また全く違うテーマに育っ足を踏み入れてしまいましたそれがピューピューどぅ客当て
変わったんですけど
その位もえろてるほどで行ったほうどうせこうなったって言われたモテないんですけど
きっかけをお話すると
去年も3月に私もおばあちゃんが亡くなったんですね
で結構焦っ小さい頃おばあちゃん子だったんですけどそのおばあちゃんがいないって
いうことはちょっと受け入れやたいなって思ってたんですけど初めてあの身内のそう
言ってもに参加して花がそう
を切って超すごいて韓服したんです
なんかあのおばあちゃんがファー真ん中に入ってそのお花を親族で夢
穴を埋めていってワーッって巻いて
でまぁホバー点が火葬されて不明になって出てくるっての台北したときにあ
おばあちゃんは本当にいないんだなっていうのが腑に落ちたかいいか
なんかお金整理がついたんですねデパその誰か大事な人がいなくなるって結構勝利して
いたことなんですけどそれを
ん
落ち着けるパンのシステムとして送迎ってすごくすごいなって思いまして
でよく考えるとあの人類ても梱包代ずーっと止められても崇敬できたんですよ
やっぱりそのクザンに対して何かしらのシャチをするっていうの絶対必要なんだなって
思って
ブーブーんですけどこれから& a paper もそうなんですけど一般家庭にロ
ボットって言っの家庭に普及していくと思うんですよ
サティ以下新しいかあったんですねでそんな here の勝ち越しずいいかあっうっ
今日相愛のシェイクに
てシステムに則ってし腰ディープ2時間一緒にいてくれる
古典の店だかの後もっとを作ろうそんなて思って
で猿車ワンプロジェクトという作品をロシア作り始めました
これ始めを想定だとなんか今いろんなしたソーシャルメディアを使っているのでその髪
は僕みたいなものを全校てのかしてその人っぽい弁護するプログラムみたいな
作ってでローター喋らせるっていうのを想定したんですはじめの方は
ってもやっぱその五回その人っぽさがすかっていうところでちょっとですかっ
壁
に使ってしまってなんかはじめ去年のクラスぐらいに
ペッパーを使って飯制度を続けるロボットみたいも作ったんですけど
なんか違うなっていう凍っちゃう
なんか明治さんを違うあもうあんわーそぉその人っぽいことペッパーん
こうゆうしゃべをしても何かそんな人たぶんアイス位そもそもこれってスマートフォン
で全然2時になっても単線まあただメッセージを伝達するはだけだったらその二全然
いいし
アワーだこのああ心配を持つ
by て扱ってるから残せる物って何なんだろう結構考えてたんですね
でもうガーッと運んで方向転換してかもいわゆるメッセージとか意味ないよと言語情報
も止めてもノンバーバル
いわゆるシレン5情報に使えましたよーするには髪はも意味内容とかでなくってかその
人の顔とか
おい室とか曲とかバックチャームもして腐ったわ笑カバーの性みたいなものをまず徹底
的に再現するで公募しました
やっぱその1
その人と去って後何を喋るかってゆーりはまー人は見た目が8割ありますけどその人は
見た目とか手配に議論すればをすごく多いになってそんだけで気がついたんです
で行ったのがを画面を3 d スキャンします
亜門
今朝も開院してまでそれを繰りでペイントします
でさらにその事前収録した音声とその仕草
動きみたいなものとくっだ組み合わせてモーションプログラムをするとこんな感じで
うんアティパサーこだわった
仕組みとして司令部へ消滅するって言うことをアッアッアッアッアーやっぱし群って
設計が良く出来てるんですもともとなんかその誰かと距離感をとるための期間とで
ちょうどよくもともと収益を起こし設計されてるなって思って
で行ったのが6年タブレットがあるんですよそこで実は視力異常漢文の制定その人が
上手くなってから
でその西洋のメカ白泥おくグリシンと無茶なもあるんですそれがバンバン
遠田買って薄れていくっていう間でこういうふうにその人の存在が薄くなっている感じ
を表現しました
これが実際の老舗
音も映像なんでお見せします
これは餅をイメージしてふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ撮影しました
こういうふうにロットにあのー枕ただの人格を入れるっていうシーンが次に行きます
nike ゲッター1
d っっ
1か月いましたああっ
やっぱ
足が地面についてるからにゼロスね進むと実は体が入って結構いい
んですよねカナダあるっていうのも結構して合体
やっぱ行ったり来て匹という
はっはっコレは確かにそういう関係なんだろう
やっぷーバルクない
超えたんでローカット居酒たし5シリーズくんしか一緒に過ごせるっていう
その2お祭はヤバイってい
鷺坂ばこの場合には委員会見えたりていただけるとすごく助かります
またパチスロいったもアップ
おやべえって言っちゃいますよね
そっちだけすごいですよチョッパーそれあげるから羽織っていた
ならがも自由者でしょを
me ちょっとも考えたけどずっと面白みはないという
おっかねー
これって支援が口説いて音を申し上げたい
これがだんだん感とダメだネイチャー巣作りさんおしゃべりたいことは
しゃべん福祉たので
ブーバーあらっで見てください
ん
これぐらい
は納得できるんむしろ珍客ご自分
敵へ
ましょう
栗の部分って子がない目下支部幹事
これやっぱりな例えば努力家だ
酸ケ湯はバーンうーん
これは魂が上がっていってロボットっ
ええええええ
本当に戻っていっ
ああああああ
はぁっ
という作品でございもすごいをいただきまーちょっと死んでるんですけど
うん
あっ張りがとうございました
これがプロタイプ完成したのは今年の2月ぐらいで何か
今回防ぎと完成してすぐぐらいおいては即メディアの方からの次第問い合わせてのが
あって
でこう私のですねーあっいやいますねうん丸パンに
でんごくっ展開せめてパー消化されたり
あと某テレビ番組であもうこの人が出たりですねいろいろ
ビジョンでいることがあってちょっとメディアで後にちょっとトラウマがあって星子
模索につける前に撤廃いった昨年作ったんですよ
撤廃っていうのはあのペッパーの胸部ためでと書いたんですがこれは騒動をおっぱいの
ところにあるから
竹表示してさあロットめちゃくちゃ合うっての
作ってばしたらうってん
正も大大塩蔵してまー
ロボット何やっているんだと色んな方からお叱りを頂いて
なぁ
まあまずいかなって思ってくださいましたんですけどマーレのことですね大炎上
we
をしなかったんですよ実はそれちょっとびっくりして
zfp 心がてどこか刺されるかなって尾鷲思ってたんですけどそのテレビの方へも
感想を見てるとなんか実際にあの身近な方は幕下っていう方からあーなんかすごい音
ズレシャワーを見てまだローソン
誰か居なくなった不在間を埋めるような気持ちが埋まった後が投げたとかあとは当然は
先生看護師たっていう声を色々頂いて外びっくりしたんですけど応援とか期待の声が
多かった絶対論が専門の車両されだろうと思ったら
でっ
マミ顔って不思議に思ったんですけどもう朝自然文も記者さんによると加速し強くにで
消えるっていう部分への共感が多かったみたいで
何か他の特集記事のほかも作品とスってあのずーっと
苦労したのクローバーのこいつできるって作品はあったんですけどでももともと日本人
っていう人間天井っていうか誰か人が
なくなったらその魂がまた上に上がってでまた戻ってくるという考え方を持っている
未読だと思うんですよねなので何かそういうメンタリティ+も知れ吹いて消えて
だんだん遠くなっていくっていうのがあったのかなと思いました
パソその一連の流れを通して思ったのは今ってもうカー9月の時代じゃないですか
その
頭において宗教とかねシミ先行するような方ってちょっと顔でられているというか
なんかちょっと非合理的だっていうふうに扱われがが違うんですけどでも人間でそうで
ひと間に動いてねで甘い生き物だと思ってて
まあ大事な人が亡くなった時のプレーをはせ見るとかことも知ることへの恐怖とかそう
いう奴は犯罪も空くためにやっぱし
結局て必要だと思う絶対になくならないというか
宗教画になっていたその機能の一部を
のプロ g 真逆にその中継を投下していったテクノロジーように
また[ __ ]にはできないかっていう試み私が入れたかったなあというふうに一連の流れを
通すに痩せてました
でとはいえなんか作品まだまだこれは幹事役ではなくてももカクテルで今やろうとする
のがもうすぐさんは再現性を高めるためにあの進退をんま誰か再現する時の収録セット
を強化して思っています具体的に言うと何故か sabelt 気のせいべえさんも
モーション客提案してそのデータと鉄板連動させていく
再現できるなるとかあとはすごくやりたいなって思ってるのがある程度高品質が高まっ
たらもう一般の方から俺を作ってくれとかあと大事な人をつくってくれてそういう依頼
も受け付けていきたいなぁと思ってますこれも同社のアート作品とスって意外とそう
いう需要があるようなし痩せました
ってもう一個すごいやりたいのが大附と育ってやりたい
うって何かっていうと全角が売買れてるんです
例えば自分をキャラクター人格と
買おうと決めさとかこういったゴロゴロセットセット売りみたいなセットアップロード
日なんですねやって栄光いろんなハペニー本ロボットできる
入ってくると思うんですいろんなティブロン
じゃない家庭に自分がばらまかれるみたいな
はっはっは
カーンアポ人格オークションできるかなと思って自分の姉さんがこれだけ上がっていく
のかそういうちょっと
イヤー有名人だと結構高値に売れるかなとかそういうことをいろいろ考えてちょっと
これやりたいなと思っています
場所にアンドロイドをつけるよりも全然安い青二葉山数千万とかわかると思うんです
android つけるかもうこれやったも
もう中11回かないかぐらいで作っやっていかないなんて作れるので非常に安価です
で打っ
はい
あの今ってそうに本店作用ですねあもう
1どこで地震があるかは考えしてい流しについて意識してもは難しい状況だと思うん
ですよ
でもそういう状況でも皆
自分は死ぬことについて公に語る事って文化
ないと思うんですけど今回あの子未遂の作品を一生懸命作って
もうやっぱ私たちは死ぬ死ぬがっていうのがおでんの配布に落ちましたまぁ明日死ぬか
も線ないしちゃんと炭を待っただけかもしれないんですけどまあいずれにしろ
シルバーも違う前でもそのでたに自分達もいますとセットになってるし終わりについて
考えることで逆にいうとまあ生きること長さ
眉を生きるかとか覚えずに自分が生きた証を残したいかっての販売ことに繋がるので
そしてこうこれは
めっちゃぽてっているのは言葉という風に考えが変わってきました
ものでマッハもの
ますしのデザインって結構色々あると思っててもせよ自分もコピーを作ったんですけど
そしたらなんかちょっと死にそうって思った時にくださいマシンならアイスが仮に
るって思えるようになったり
なんか行ける時のチョコを温度感が変わるかなって思ったんですねモンデオの皆さんあ
もう
知りついて考える事って色々あると思うんで
意外と
考えると勝手にぜひ考えてください吉野アームレス a 3シャーマンプロジェクトっ
ていうロボットが案もその考えるためも助けになればいいなと思っていますよまあ変え
させています
ありがとうございます